[Music]
[Applause]
today he's the popular chris
collinsworth who joins us uh on the
program where do you want to start chris
which game
oh i thought i'd start with my free
mercedes that i did for coming on your
show is that right so you're just
giving them away look out in the
driveway look out in the driving have
holly go out in the driveway it's right
there
right there okay which game you want to
start with
um let's start with tampa okay
i was surprised i mean there's a couple
things that
that surprised me but the one thing i
think will get overlooked is
i thought that was a tampa win a true
tampa win
tom will get the credit but that tampa
defense did some special things against
aaron rodgers that
i i think will be understated chris um
how would you describe what that
philosophy was
well i i think that you have to hey i
think you're dead on
um and and maybe in part we finally
saw the david bacchiari injuries show up
in this game you know because we saw
a week ago that it didn't show up it was
like oh it just looked like the green
bay offense it was
no worries at all they finally figured
it out and aaron's going to do what he
does they're going to run the ball maybe
a little bit more and
but you know it's gonna be fun but for
the second straight time now the tampa
bay defense
dominated aaron rodgers and you know i
i studied the the first game between
these two teams
uh because i had one of them the
following week whatever so i got to
watch
all the blitzing that tampa did and you
know they really
impacted aaron rodgers in a way that i
just had not seen anybody really impact
him
and then you come back in this game and
yeah they had some five-man pressures
and they did a little bit of that
but there was a lot of one-on-one
winning going on
on the defensive line of the buccaneers
and one of the problems you have when
you have a superstar out and we'll get
to this in the kansas city game now
because they're going to be missing both
of their tackles
but without david bacchiari in there all
of a sudden
all the help that you could give the
other guys on that offensive line
goes away now you're one on one
at other positions as well as the left
tackle position
and that could always be assumed if you
were aaron rodgers if you have bakiari
in there
you just assume that that backside is
covered
so you're really only worried about four
offensive linemen and doing whatever you
need to do to protect them
yeah but you see um and this was a
depleted secondary too
like they didn't even have a healthy
secondary and they were putting all that
pressure on aaron rodgers
um it let me start with the packers you
didn't take advantage of tom brady three
interceptions in the second
if i would have said brady's throwing
three picks in the second half
you just assume that they're going to be
able to take advantage they only cashed
in with six points
what was the big problem do you think
with that offense and not being able to
do anything
you know i think a you have to give
credit to
what they did defensively you know i
maybe it was just the confidence they
built in the first game where they
utterly they were down 10 nothing in
that first game playing in tampa
and came back and won 38 to 10. and
the other part of it is and you hit on
this that
you know you start the game without
winfield you lose whitehead the other
safety
in the game so now what you're really
saying is if i'm going to bring pressure
i'm going to trust jamel dean and sean
murphy bunting and carlton davis
one on one out there on the outside you
know to make plays
and did they always stop them no they
didn't but that was a young group
coming into this season when i analyzed
the
the tampa bay team i said they'll go as
far as this secondary takes them
you know they're all babies they're all
young you know winfield's out now
but they're all young players and
sometimes that's a good thing you know i
mean dan you know there was a time when
you and i were
young and dumb and i didn't know any
better of course i went to the super
bowl my first year of course i went to
the pro bowl
my first year in the league this happens
to everybody right this is a long way
from the florida gators
going oh 10 and 1 my junior year so i
mean sometimes it just works out and you
build this confidence and it starts
going
um but i i really think that looking now
um at what the getting vitaveya back and
and having some push
you know vidaveya was the best player on
this buck's defense
when he was playing earlier in the year
he was the best
and what devin white did a week ago in
that game and levonte david and barrett
and then dominic and sue and jason
pierre paul look like jason pierre-paul
again
all of a sudden you go wow you know
those three interceptions
at least two of them i can't remember
the third at least two of them were
three and outs
you know it was it was three and out and
that's
typically when aaron rodgers buries you
when you get one of those quick changes
and he gets the ball back in his hands
they've got something in their hip
pocket and he buries you
let's go to the end of the first half
how does that happen
with that kind of defensive formation
and scotty miller gets behind you
i i'm just going to take a guess i'm i'm
sitting there watching the game with
our family and i said i think he's going
to throw a hail mary here
because i didn't think that um
that green bay would allow them to throw
a quick out right to get in field goal
range so if you're not going to be
gifted that
then i'm just gonna take a shot of the
hail mary and
see what happens here right um but in
reality
they could have had the quick out and
they could have had the deep ball
um i i i'm gonna say that for king
defensively maybe he was thinking about
that
maybe he was thinking they're going to
run they're going to run a 10 yard out
here and get in field goal range and so
i'm going to i'm going to undercut this
sucker and pick six it and
you know i maybe i because otherwise
you know you're at the very least in
three deep or quarters or at least
too deep with two guys sort of sitting
back on the goal line somewhere
but when he launched it i said i mean i
was thinking right away this is a
touchdown i mean tom brady's not
throwing this ball
unless scotty miller who's really a bit
of the unsung hero of this team now with
the antonio brown out
coming down with that thing it was it
was an amazing play and it
lost the green bay packers and aaron
rodgers a chance
to go the super bowl yeah and people
don't understand you know scottie miller
was a
a track guy in in high school and and
you know a 4-3-9 guy at the combine
you know he's not like edelman he's not
one of those not wes wilker
he's actually got straight ahead you
know track speed
but you know let's go to the uh two
minutes to go
and the uh whatever you know we're third
and eight
you gotta score a touchdown there rogers
you know they had three plays where they
were going into the end zone there
and then you had the fourth down where
they kicked the field goal how about the
how about all four bl plays together
though chris if you were going to
dissect those on what the philosophy was
of green bay
and that they ended with kicking a field
goal
yeah i mean they came back to a play
that little double move
you know where he came in and went back
up so you can't blame him for that that
one that would look good before
um i thought the real sequence came down
to
third down um because on third down
you have to tell your quarterback are we
going for this on fourth down
right you have to and i'm gonna take it
one step further than that
i'm gonna say this is not a decision for
the head coach
i think it's in today's day and age
and almost every team has this and if
the green bay packers don't have this
they need to have this they need to have
a full-time
guy and maybe a full-time staff that
understands the analytics of where we
are in the game
right so it's let's take what the
situation was
it was just outside the two minute
warning so you're gonna have three
timeouts
and you're gonna have a two minute
warning right so effectively four
four timeouts so now you're also
in a position where no matter what you
do
if you kick a field goal the goal is
still the same
you still have to score a touchdown
under no circumstances do you not have
to score a touchdown
in that situation so you're going to
take
two shots at scoring a touchdown you're
going to take it on
fourth down and if you make it two-point
conversion
but more importantly if you miss it if
you don't score the touchdown there
you're leaving tampa and tom brady the
ball
on the seven or eight yard line wherever
they were in that situation
i can just tell you being inside your
own 10 yard line
with a trip to the super bowl on the
line
is so significant in what you can do
defensively
your play calling how you attack it the
whole thing
so there should have been so they played
for one
you know one shot and a touchdown that
would have won the game as opposed to
needing a two-point conversion so i
i mean let's not this guy's not crazy
right i mean there is a thing
but there's no way in that set of
circumstances
if they had the right analytics team
with them
they don't tell you know matt you got to
take
a shot for two touchdowns here talking
to chris collins worth nbc sunday night
football
and i agree with you um i you know i'm
watching it wondering
okay the worst case scenario is you
leave brady
inside his 10. and then you take your
chances at getting the ball back
then scoring a touchdown two-point
conversion go into overtime um
the kansas city buffalo game i kept
thinking if you're buffalo
you can't go with the same script you
had the last time you played them
can you be aggressive enough with kansas
city
like the approach if you were coaching
buffalo
the approach would have been much
different than you saw last night with
sean mcdermott and josh allen
probably but that's easy to say today
you know i mean
i saw the results of the game right um
a couple of things i would have wanted
to
i mean patrick mahomes was the story of
the whole week right
it was turf toe and it was coming off
concussion
i don't think the concussion had
anything to do with anything that he did
in the game so i'm just going to erase
that one
the turf toe i don't know that we really
found out if it mattered or not
you know i kind of wanted to see i mean
you know what he does with that little
back pedal and throw of his right
but at some point he has to make a quick
stop and pivot and get back into his
throwing motion
i would want to see him at least in the
first quarter of that game run around a
little bit
you know you had a nine to nothing lead
the chiefs do what
did what they always do which is they're
going to spot you
it's like when i used to race my dad you
know he would spot me 10 yards before
the race would start and so they spotted
the nine points which is usual for
kansas city
and then here it comes right and i'm not
saying that they could have impacted
mahomes but i would have at least
early in that game wanted him thinking
about that turf toe
you know and you've got something and we
saw it
impact him a little bit the week before
and how he was throwing the ball when
you have
something and he's the best player on
the field
i i want to challenge that a little bit
more than i think they did
how would you feel if you're a buffalo
fan today good
really good i i i i thought
josh was not anywhere close to his best
in this game
um and he reverted back to his weakness
when he was struggling and he wasn't
struggling much this year i don't wanna
he's an ungodly player i mean he really
is and i think he's gonna be
great great great i really do um but
young quarterbacks
when they're in big moments or in really
tough situations or under pressure
do the same thing they scramble right
scramble right is a sign
of we have to improve this
right patrick mahomes is just as good
going to his left scrambling as he is to
the right
when you scramble to one side of the
field especially to the right side of
the field
people have defenses have seen that so
much now josh has the ability to throw
it all the way back across the field a
la
john elway or somebody like that but for
the most part
you're you're taking a third of the
field away from what the defense has to
cover
and in addition you're also telling them
if we bring any kind of pressure off the
left side at all
he's going to move to his right so you
can begin to play that a little bit more
young quarterbacks always do what watch
the next preseason
watch drafted quarterbacks
i mean nine times out of ten when
they're flushed out of the pocket
they're moving to their right and
everybody goes
okay we'll give them three years and
they'll figure this out
matthew stafford fits best where
oh boy um i think new england
you know that that feels like the
obvious choice
to me um but you know dak prescott
is gonna determine a lot of things in my
mind
uh because i i'm assuming that gets
signed with the dallas cowboys but man
after this 2020 and 2021
and covet i'm not assuming anything
anymore i you know i
i just don't know what's going to happen
um you know is is their car going to be
in play
is you know i mean there's gonna be some
guys out there and and these
the the draft choices this year are
going to be
good as well and i think i think the the
question that has to be answered
for me in new england is is this a
long term or a short term play i mean
bill belichick
i'm going to assume he wants to go get
don shula's record which means that he's
probably has another four or five years
at least
to try and go get that um if he doesn't
and this is a two-year game plan and he
wants to retire you know only bill knows
this
uh then matthew stafford feels like a
great fit to me you know
pop in there let's see what we can do
let's see what we can we can do
quickly uh if he starts moving up in the
draft
they go get a play i'm like all right
this man he's never going to retire
um so there's there's a lot of different
things in play but
but for matthew stafford i i think he's
i think he still has it i i do i i've
always thought that he was a better
player than what the results
uh indicated you know but
uh but who knows great to talk to you
chris we appreciate your time as always
hope you're well
thank you dan good talking to you buddy
that's chris collins we're sunday night
football
color analyst